that's one of the reasons why he's upset
now yeah because they're treating him
like a guy right who's been wishy-washy
yeah they're treating him like a guy
who's been greedy who they can't wait to
replace him with someone else that they
draft in round one and on that point
chris brett favre inevitably chiming in
on aaron rodgers i haven't heard this i
had someone send this to me 15 minutes
before show time send it to pete
demelitis it's plugged into the show so
let's have a listen for the first time
to what brett favre has had to say about
the ongoing and fairly recent grand
scheme of things dysfunction between the
packers and aaron rodgers
knowing aaron and i think i know him
fairly well
um
if if he has a grudge
whether it be against the organization
or a player
or an arch rival or
family friends
he ain't budging i don't see him coming
back and and saying
if this is not resolved however whatever
the issue is if it's not resolved
um
or even if it's resolved but
he feels like they got it one up on him
he ain't gonna play
knowing aaron he would he would sit now
it's not you know he would forego a lot
of money
yeah look farv knows rogers well he does
and f favre has been on the wrong side
of a rogers grudge barb has done things
to deserve a grudge from aaron rodgers
in fact
the reality that farvin rogers found a
way to mend fences it's amazing actually
that that farv is like the only guy
who has ever managed to ungrudge aaron
rodgers maybe i need to talk to farv
twice
see what i can do to get aaron rodgers
not to fire an arrow at my
[Laughter]
but i don't know how farv did it now now
now i don't know that what he said
about this situation is going to get him
back on the list the ryan howard you
know
marking your name down off on my list
gif from the office but uh i think he's
accurate right nobody holds a grudge
like aaron rodgers and so unless this
gets resolved to his satisfaction he
isn't coming back no and i i wouldn't
think rogers would get mad at anything
farv said there i think far you know
that's one of those where he's far just
given his honest take
and he he's seen aaron rodgers in action
knows what he is i think there's a lot
of people in football that have that
feeling that aaron rodgers is is like
this and this could be real he is the
type of guy that's just you know a
stubborn sob and he might sit out
football or or do what he's got to do i
i don't know that'll be some decision i
mean unlike anything we've ever seen
before really but you know yeah i think
you're right favre farve has a good feel
for how aaron rodgers is the wrath of
what aaron rodgers can give out if he
feels wronged
and uh
i mean yeah i don't know mike i mean
really like what's
in your heart of hearts again we don't
know and hopefully we'll hear more info
as we go forward here but do you like do
you think pasta and meatballs gut is
roger what's going to happen is roger's
going to be playing for the packers this
year is he going to draw a concrete line
in the sand
well remember we talked yesterday about
the
very real possibility that he'll just
show up and act like it was no big deal
and try to get the fans on his side and
stick it to management every week win
the mob the maximus commodus fight and
gladiator where the mob is caught in the
middle and whoever can can get the mob
on their side ultimately wins this fight
and if he can do that and then maybe
next year walk away without alienating
the fans my only concern is
if that's the end game
the fans are already turning on him if
he's going to implement the
steve urkel did i do that
reaction he better do it publicly now
i've heard that he's told at least one
teammate i don't know what the big deal
is
well
that's not something that you say
privately at this point that's something
you got to say publicly you got to go on
pat mcafee's show with aj hawk your
former teammate you got to say i don't
know where all this is coming from yeah
i've been paying attention to the last
five days this is this this is nuts i
never said it just like he did he set
the precedent this is a point sharing
williams made yesterday if we're gonna
make fun of toothpaste back in the
toothpaste holder i got to give her some
love for this too okay she made that
point yesterday yeah when when rogers
lit the fuse in the post game of the nfc
championship with that comment that set
everyone
ablaze right incorrectly yeah whoa whoa
whoa he corrected it two days later dead
you're right now we're six days later
and it's worse than it was the last time
and it's building every day right you if
you're gonna go
i don't know what the big deal is i
never said any of that stuff i don't you
know i got no issues i'm going to be
there if you're going to do that
you better get on the horn with somebody
and you better say so because
it already feels like it's too late
it is i think it is toothpaste
back yes and the toothpaste toothpaste
holder right i'm with you i i think it
is too you know i i to me it's
it's it's all signs point to
the leaks came from rogers camp all
signs point to
yes it's too late for rogers to correct
the narrative because this narrative is
is real it's the truth so
i you know again yeah i don't know where
he's gonna go from from now you know
from from here but i think it is a a
point here where he's going to have to
say something publicly to let everybody
know where he is and how he feels about
this situation
if he does want to get you know public
opinion maybe back on his side a little
bit but you're because it is it's
totally swaying over to green bay's
advantage right now over the last few
days
i've heard
that there are some folks who are
suggesting
that this wasn't leaked by rogers or his
camp okay
let's let's indulge right let's do that
because i thought so at first i i i will
be well let me just say because i know i
said it maybe a little on monday or even
on friday i i wondered too whether it
was i was one of those guys right
because i went what's the point of
putting this out now a lot of the
quarterback seats are already filled why
didn't he do this a few like this can't
come from him
but i've talked to enough people in the
nfl to think that i was wrong about that
go ahead let's take a step back let's
just look at it without the benefit of
the things that you and i have both
heard right reliable sources let's take
a step back
why in the hell
would the packers
be the ones to leak this because it's
one or the other
it's not somebody who just happened to
be in the right place at the right time
when they witnessed an argument between
aaron rodgers and mark murphy or brian
guticune store matt lafleur this is
somebody
on the inside
who has decided
to let people on the outside know what's
going on let's just apply common sense
occam's razor you know about occam's
razor we've talked about it before the
most accurate explanation for something
is the most simple the most direct the
most obvious the most obvious is rogers
and his camp were the ones to light this
fuse especially when you look at the
timing it's the perfect time to serve
revenge on the packers for what they did
last year the first day of the draft
yeah when they traded up to take jordan
love the first day of the next draft you
unleash hell on the packers after you've
told them for three months give me what
i want or first day of the draft all
bets are off
if the packers were the ones leaking
this why would they have stopped
why wouldn't they keep leaking stuff see
i the packers don't do business that way
the packers don't want this out there
the packers are trying to weigh trying
to find a way to fix this before it does
damage to roger's relationship with the
fan base they want him to be able to
come back and everything's fine they got
no reason to leak this rogers does
rogers is trying to implement what he's
been trying to do behind the scenes for
three months was to get out of green bay
yeah no i mean i think everything you
said is right there there's no doubt
about it i mean
one because we know green bay wants to
make it work and they want them back
right now so you're right i mean it
wouldn't make sense for them to release
all this and cause
nine issues for themselves to deal with
here you know in a time period like you
talked about where they're dealing with
the draft and everything like that
right if you're at that point you just
trade him right you don't have to start
some campaign against him just trade the
guy that's exactly right that's where
like all right like if you asked me like
two things to why green bay might have
done it right and i had somebody smart
in the nfl say this to me early on now
obviously i don't believe that's the
case but one it does turn public opinion
on rogers if they did want to like start
you know playing hardball with them and
two that maybe the releasing of the
49ers trade offer and things like that
starts a baseline conversation for other
teams to know like hey it's going to
take
here's what the 49ers kind of offered us
you're going to have to offer us a whole
lot more that would be the only reasons
but that doesn't really make sense
and i'm with you
it seems to be way more on the the
rogers side here
you don't need to play those games when
you've got aaron rodriguez no you have
that's right wait until june the 2nd
call george payton the gm of the broncos
and say what are you going to give us
for aaron rodgers and when that's right
when peyton pulls himself up off the
floor because he's fallen out of his
chair at the prospect of upgrading from
drew lock and teddy bridgewater to aaron
rodgers that's when he tells you what
he's willing to give you yeah so you
don't need to play those games and the
packers historically don't play those
degrees they are careful and cautious
and old school and there's nothing to be
gained
for them
for the team
for the corporation
for anyone no to have these public
fights you're right there's nothing to
be gained
um so
it's it's all rogers it's all his camp
and
the the see that the the thing is
he's got a plan
that he is unfolding
as he sees fit
and there's a certain fascination from
my perspective to see how this guy is
going to make his next move and how he
will couch it because when you have that
reputation for being brilliant and he
does because he is what goes along with
that is the reality that people are
going to look at you and say there are
no accidents there are no coincidences
everything is meticulously thought out
everything is meticulously planned
everything
is meticulously executed
and
we're just the audience yeah we're in
the splash zone as we wait for shamu to
jump out of the water and do his next
trick
yeah no
no doubt i mean well i'm gonna be
interested to see where this goes i i
really am you know i i do have the sense
that rogers is the kind of guy that
really will play hardball and be you
know would be willing to maybe retire or
step away from the game but also like i
just again i go back to that
man he's at the end of his career it's
still a good football team he's playing
high level he's playing at such a high
level still do you really want to you
know forego maybe the end of your career
a bunch of great years here that you
still have left you know just to make a
point to green bay and whatever else
there and you know as a fan and if i was
advising aaron rodgers i would say no
you know please try to go back to green
bay if that's the case or force the
trade here but i don't want to see you
retire and be that stubborn to where you
don't play ball again
think of it this way too
when we would
prioritize the best possible outcomes
for the packers best possible outcome
we keep aaron rodgers
on a year-to-year contract
preserving the ability if we see any
sign of slippage to trade him
and go with jordan love that's their
best possible outcome that's what
they've been trying to do right okay
beneath that
and this is what i'm trying to figure
out
would the packers prefer
to trade aaron rodgers get value for him
but have to see him play for someone
else possibly win a super bowl or more
with someone else or would they prefer
he never play again
and
they get back 23 million that they've
already paid him in bonus money they get
back the 6.8 million dollar roster bonus
that he earned earlier this offseason
that may or may not have actually been
paid if it hasn't been paid it won't be
if it has been paid they can get it back
that's almost 30 million dollars that
the corporation gets back
and they never have
to see him
in a different
uniform right what would you prefer if
you're a packers fan maybe that's a poll
question i think if you prefer the
packers to get three first-round picks
and trade aaron rodgers or prefer that
aaron rodgers never play for another
team i'm gonna put that on twitter i
like it i think that's a good one and
you know what do you think the packers
prefer uh you can make the argument
we're fine with him never playing again
there's gonna i think there's gonna be a
significant vote for that right because
they're they're not gonna wanna see that
and they're gonna be a little bitter
towards him and they'd rather not see
him get any gratification or anything
what he wants here out of this situation
um
i think and he can't prove you're wrong
no he can't embarrass you no he can't
get mark murphy's job on the line that's
where when you don't have an owner yeah
you got a ceo who's got to worry about
an uprising from the board of directors
the shareholders the executive committee
and there's no i told you so if aaron
rodgers goes and hosts jeopardy or does
whatever right there's no i told you so
there's no way to be proven wrong i
think ultimately i'm gonna say the three
first rounders wins out i'm gonna say it
wins out but i think it's gonna be
closer than you'd expect like a you know
a 55-45 type of victory something like
that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports